en attendant le jour prochain où ils en
recevront 1 à leur tour ils vont
remettre un grégoire ludig et david
marsais plus connu sous le nom de palm à
chaud
[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde soir là vous êtes
en train de vous dire qu'il ya un petit
problème technique mais pas du tout
faits oui en fait le fait est que je
vous entends tous les deux mais je ne
vous vois pas non non tout bête vous ne
vous n'aurez même pas vous ne nous voyez
pas parce que nous sommes invisibles à
eweek antoine comme totalement invisible
grâce à notre maîtrise des effets
visuels oui oui on a la dernière version
de photoshop et oui regardez nous
faisons coucou à benoît magimel mais ils
ne nous voient pas beaucoup à ma jumelle
non on ne voit personne c'est bien fait
alors d'accord tout ça c'est très bien
mais comment allez vous remettre un
césar un césar qui est un objet il faut
bien qu'ils aient réalisé mais regardez
antoine regarder vers le ciel où le sait
jean paul
bailly mesdames messieurs vous ne rêvez
pas vous êtes bien à paris
bravo et oui un césar qui flottent des
remettants invisible messieurs oui non
non vous pouvez pas rester dans les
coulisses cela vous gêne et les
techniciens je vous vois pas du tout bon
et bien les nommer oui on le césar des
meilleurs effets visuels sont